Mr Speaker this morning the business
secretary toured the TV studios arguing
that the turmoil in the market has
nothing to do with her budget
does the Prime Minister agree with him
what we have done
is we have
[Applause]
to sites of action to make sure that
people are not facing energy bills of
six thousand pounds 2 yes
and I think we remember the opposition
who's only talking about six months
we've also taken decisive action to make
sure that we are not facing the highest
taxes for 70 years in the face of a
global economic slowdown and what we're
making sure is that we protect our
economy there's very difficult
efficiently and as a result as a result
of our action Mr Speaker and this has
been independently corroborated we will
see higher growth and lower inflation
up here
Mr Speaker avoiding the question ducking
responsibility lost in denial no wonder
investors have no confidence in her
government and this is why it matters a
few weeks ago Zach and Rebecca from
Wolverhampton were all set to buy their
first home then the government's
borrowing spree sent interest rates
spiraling and their mortgage offer was
withdrawn
I met them last week they're back to
square one unable to buy devastated sick
to the back teeth with excuses and blame
shifting just the promise to understand
why Zach and Rebecca are completely
furious with her
Mr Speaker the fact is that when I came
into office people were facing energy
bills of up to six thousand pounds
I'm sorry
Mr Speaker the party opposite a shouting
but he is opposing the very package that
we brought in in energy price guarantee
that was the major part of the mini
budget that we announced and Mr Speaker
he has refused to confirm whether or not
he backs our energy price guarantee for
two years which protects families not
just this winter but next winter what
we're seeing Mr Speaker is we are seeing
interest rates Rising globally we are
doing they are rising globally in the
face of Putin's appalling war in Ukraine
and what we are doing is helping people
with lower stamp Duty helping people
with their energy costs reducing
inflation with our energy package and
keeping taxes low and I notice that the
honorable gentleman had a damask in
conversion last night when he backed our
cut to National Insurance
[Applause]
Mr Speaker The Economist in turmoil
people are really worried this is really
not the time to descend into absolutely
nonsense attacks about last night
there's no point there's no point
there's no point trying to hide it
everyone can see what has happened the
Taurus went on a borrowing spree sending
mortgage rates through the roof they are
skyrocketing by 500 pounds a month and
for nearly 2 million homeowners their
fixed rate deals are coming to an end
next year they're worried sick and
everybody in this house knows it they
won't forgive they won't forget and nor
should they when will she stop ducking
responsibility do the right thing and
reverse her Kamikaze budget which is
causing so much pain
[Applause]
Mr Speaker last night the labor party
party supported bringing down National
Insurance
is he really
I want to the Prime Minister I'm sorry
if the wrong party doesn't but I
certainly agree
Mr Speaker I'm genuinely unclear about
what happened
I think we don't want an early bath at
this stage Rugby World Cups coming don't
start it too soon just let's hear the
questions and certainly the answer is
prime minister Mr Speaker I'm genuinely
unclear
for what
as to what the labor party's policy is
on our energy price guarantee it was the
biggest part it was the biggest part of
our mini budget are the oppositions
saying they want to revert it and they
want to see people facing energy bills
of 6 000 pounds is that what he's saying
here's Dumber Mr Speaker the the Primus
knows very well that on this side we
voted against the National Insurance in
the first place
she she voted for it so who's doing the
U-turn
honestly last week the Prime Minister
was forced to u-turn on her unfunded tax
cut for the super wealthy this week
she's beginning to realize that she
needs to extend the windfall tax one
step behind the CEO of shell but she's
still going ahead with 18 billion pounds
of tax cuts for the richest businesses
and they didn't even ask for it she's
still gift wrapped a stamp Duty cup for
landlords just as renters feel the pinch
and she's still holding out tax cuts for
those who live off stocks and shares why
does she expect working people to pick
up the bill for her unfunded tax cuts
for those at the top
thank you
I noticed that the leader of the
opposition is still not saying whether
or not he supports our energy price
guarantee
very relevant Mr Speaker because it is
the biggest part
it is the biggest part of our mini
budget it's the biggest part of the mini
budget the fact is that all the
opposition have said is that people
should be supported for six months does
he think that in March pensioners should
be facing very high energy bills because
that's what will happen if he doesn't
support our energy price guarantee
Mr Speaker not even attempting to answer
the questions now I gently remind her
that the idea of freezing energy bills
was a labor idea which she then took on
during her leadership contest the Prime
Minister said and I quote her exactly
I'm very clear I'm not planning public
spending reductions is she going to
stick to that
absolutely absolutely
what we are look Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker we are spending
we are spending almost a trillion pounds
of public spending we were spending 700
billion back in 2010. what we will make
sure is that over the medium term the
debt is falling but we will do that not
by cutting public spending but by making
sure we spend public money well and the
honorable gentleman talks about our
spending which he doesn't seem to
support on the energy price guarantee
but the reality is he can't criticize us
on one hand for spending money on the
other hand claiming we're cutting public
expenditure
they can cheer I hope they listen very
very carefully to that last answer
because other people have listened very
very carefully to it
who voted uh
who voted for this
who voted for this who voted for this
not homeowners paying an extra 500 extra
on their mortgages who voted this not
working people paying for tax cuts to
the largest companies who voted for this
not even most of the MPS behind her who
know who know you can't pay for tax cuts
on the never never does she think does
she think the public will ever forgive
the conservative party if they keep on
defending this madness and go ahead with
our Kamikaze budget thank you
Mr Speaker what our budget has delivered
is security
[Applause]
facts made sure that we're going to see
higher economic growth lower inflation
and more opportunities the way that we
will get our country growing is through
more jobs more growth more opportunities
not through higher taxes higher spending
and his friends in the union stopping
hard-working people get to work
[Applause]